réal girard est un intellectuel
après des études en philosophie au
québec et un doctorat en littérature à
paris il est revenu chez lui en alberta
il s'est lancé dans le camionnage
ça a été plus difficile pour moi l'avant
de ma classe à apprendre à conduire le
camion c'est son frère jean claude très
débrouillard qui a eu l'idée de créer
une compagnie de transport ce qui est
plus facile mais
c'est difficile de pas de voir que ça se
passerait crise et un pue le nombre de
puits de creuser le nombre de lycéens à
croire qu'il ya autour oui au début on
en voyait juste un ici alors qu'après ça
il y en avait partout partout ça sortait
de terre comme les champignons
il y en a plus de 50000 dans la région
il les réserves de sables bitumineux
serait immense 10% de celle de l'alberta
ce sont ces vices qui creusent à 1500
mètres sous terre pour extraire le
pétrole qui est très lourd
il est ensuite mélangée à de grandes
quantités d'eau qu'on fait chauffer dans
ses réservoirs pour en extraire l'or
noir les gens qui viennent visiter un
peu la région la première chose qui les
surprend c'est qu'ils voient pas cette
énorme trou
c'est immense trou qu'on voie des airs
le quand on parle qu'en fait des
documentaires sur le pétrole
s'est plaint petit trou qu'on voit peu
près pas et puis il ya des chants autour
de ça alors
vu
que la vie normale continue
et deux frères ont déjà eu quatre
véhicules
c'est aujourd'hui un fils qui gère
l'entreprise un camion a été vendue et
un chauffeur mis à pied car avec la
chute des prix les pétrolières ont
réduit de 6% leur rémunération et
dahmane pol ccc sort il dispose comme à
là ok on devrais tu faire si on devrait
être su qu'aux non on vous paye la tête
1-1 aux six armes en venant 100 membres
restent à bord prenant exact travaille
pas avec ajouté
mais le travail continue jour et nuit
sept jours sur sept
richard offre est originaire de
paspébiac en gaspésie il est arrivé en
alberta il y a huit ans etc
pourquoi le phare air pour trois fois et
même de voir qu'à toi tout dépend des
erreurs que les gros travail il a
commencé comme chauffeur il possède
maintenant six camions car l'extraction
n'arrête jamais
et l'impact sur l'environnement dans
tout ça l'avenir de la planète nos vieux
routiers sont pragmatiques
quand je regarde je vois dans ma cuisine
je jouais mon frigidaire et je vois que
c'est déjà fait a frappé de plastique
je me dis jeunes et en bonne business
parce que j'adore mais pour les dommages
que ça fait on ne voit pas vraiment de
l'hôte c'est sûr que on a quand même une
conscience écologique dont on y pense qu
et nous ici on reste juste près de tully
et puis tu sais faut y voir parce que
les compagnies pétrole viendrait le vide
et dans tant de dire si on veut pas
détruire l'industrie pétrolière mais on
se pose des questions
mais ces sables bitumineux ont fait la
prospérité de la région et personne ici
imagine vraiment leur déclin militaire
semblable
les y ont tous baissé on s'est ajusté on
a réussi à passer au travers
lyon remonte un peu prêt payant de 5,24
grands bobos la main un port sûr travail
à part à moins qu'ils arrêtent de
forkhill ville complètement